Americans are feeling some relief from
Gas and Grocery bills with inflation
falling to the lowest rate in more than
two years Prices rose three percent in
June now that's significantly lower than
last June when prices were up more than
nine percent from the year before CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
is here to break it all down my box is
on recycling day so put this into
context for us what does this mean for
folks at home well you'll
notice that it's cheaper to fill up your
car this year than last year food prices
are down for a lot of items though some
of those shelf steady items are still
expensive like potato chips and I think
that there's one component of the
Consumer Price Index that is a little
bit of a thorn in consumer's wallets and
that is rent and we are seeing rents
starting to come down in more recent
data but I think overall this is good
news for consumers but for many
Americans prices are still high for a
lot of the things they need all the time
now we've been watching the FED
aggressively raise interest rates did
this help kind of slow the inflation you
know when you think back March of 2022
the FED started this aggressive rate
hike campaign 10 consecutive meetings
five full percentage points and yes it
slowed the economy down but also a lot
of the supply chain issues that we saw
amid the pandemic and the war in Ukraine
those have also eased together it has
pushed down the overall inflation rate
and it really has helped a lot of people
that we've seen wages increase as well
so all eyes will be on the FED in their
meeting in two weeks
um should we expect the FED to drop
rates the FED is probably going to
actually increase rates by another
quarter of a percentage point and the
reason is they are worried that certain
prices are still sticky and very high
they want to push that down they've got
to balance it they don't want to push us
into a recession so far no recession and
that's the good news and you said the r
word recession do you believe that that
is a possibility should we still have
that fear I think it's looming it is
looming but I would say that as many
people who predicted a recession this
year they're reversing that and right
now there is no recession maybe at the
end of the year but right now none still
I appreciate you dollar dollar Jill
y'all